next gen Consuelos right there with
Daddy Consuelos over his shoulder
Michael is one of the sexiest people
alive
are you kidding me next gen Kelly Ripa
seemingly just found out her eldest son
Michael is one of People's sexiest men
alive on live TV in our family
everything is left unset
during Wednesday's episode of Live with
Kelly and Ryan Kell's co-host Ryan
Seacrest brought out the mag and showed
the 25 year old shirtless snap alongside
a throwback pick of his look-alike dad
Kelly's hubby Mark Consuelos and the mom
of three was shook you would think he
would tell us so we'd pick up a couple
of copies for the grandparents
we blinked unfortunately and now they
are grown adults it's funny I forget
that they look alike until I see like
photos of them and like that it's crazy
it really is crazy clearly I'm not the
only one who thinks they could pass as
brothers I always considered you just a
handsome lovely fellow uh conscientious
hard-working diligent respectful I had
no idea that you were considered
has found his father to be sexy he's a
great husband he's a great father he's a
great guy but he's a great friend that's
the greatest thing he is a friend and if
you have him as a friend you've hit the
jackpot as for Michael he could couldn't
help but gush over his famous parents
during a chat with the mag about the
high honor my parents went to great
efforts and just kind of raised me as
you know quote unquote normally is
possible like I didn't really know
things were different except I grew up
with them on a soap opera now Michael is
following in his mom and dad's Showbiz
footsteps starring alongside Jenna Dewan
in the lifetime flick Let's Get Physical
a film produced by Jenna Kelly and Mark
I respect your parents so much and I
think just personally I respect and like
professionally what they have been able
to create is amazing but honestly
they're just really good people so it
was really fun to produce this so what
was it like working for his folks it's
not just on this my parents are my
bosses in life you know I wasn't much of
a sports guy growing up when I was at a
cross-country meet my parents were
around I'm like I have to really bring
it because they're watching which is
this is their but you know they had a
big hand in this so I wanted to make
sure I did a really good job because
they were watching I think it it was a
good motivator it would definitely
knowing that they were involved
[Music]
thank you